so after his completely farcical
presidential announcement on Twitter
spaces uh Florida Republican Governor
Ron DeSantis gave his first interview as
a presidential candidate he gave this
interview to Trey Gowdy who was guest
hosting on Fox News and DeSantis
suffered what I call a talking point
coma he couldn't stop repeating the word
woke he also threw in an anti-semitic
conspiracy theory for good measure right
I mean he is running as a republican
after all let's take a look at this and
this is just if you thought the
announcement was bad when DeSantis
actually gets a chance to speak it gets
even worse so let's start there here is
Ron DeSantis with a talking point coma
can't stop saying woke well first of all
the woke mind virus is basically a form
of cultural Marxism at the end of the
day it's an attack on the truth and
because it's a war on truth I think we
have no choice but to wage a war on woke
so how does that I work for a president
some of it may be the bully pulpit being
willing to tell the truth and not being
deluded by ideology which we see in many
aspects of our society there you go so
woke woke woke Florida is where woke
goes to die we will end woke so please
understand that the term cultural
Marxism is nothing but a far right wing
conspiracy theory that is let me to to
put it lightly often tinged with
anti-Semitism I I get emails every time
one of these right winger starts talking
about cultural Marxism people write in
say David what the hell I know Marxism
the economic theory what on Earth is
cultural Marxism when the right uses the
term cultural Marxism they are talking
about a supposed leftist agenda that
wants to undermine Traditional Values it
wants to erode societal Norms it wants
to promote political correctness and
police police speech and this sort of
thing often what they accuse George
Soros of is tantamount to the very
cultural Marxism they claim exists and
they say that this so-called cultural
Marxism is a conspiracy propagated by
left-wing intellectuals left-wing
activists Democrats
Etc they want to infiltrate and control
institutions including Academia media
entertainment and they want to reshape
culture to fit their ideology now
according to that perspective
cultural marxists are accused of
manipulating language promoting and
using identity politics advocating for
social justice issues and LGBT rights
and so on and so forth at the expense of
individual freedoms and Liberty and so
on and so forth the most important thing
to understand about so-called cultural
Marxism is that it essentially does not
exist and what I mean by that is
Marxism focuses on economic structures
and class struggle that's the first
thing to understand it doesn't actually
focus on cultural or social issues
although Marxism does acknowledge that
culture and Society will be shaped by
the economic system that's number one so
even the term doesn't really make sense
secondly the entire emergence of the
term cultural Marxism came from a
misinterpretation of actual Marxism
that's number two and then number three
there's also no marxists in the United
States now I know you might go to uh you
know the local Magic the Gathering
tournament and meet an actual Marxist
who understands Marxist ideology and
says they subscribe to it and I'm not
insulting Magic the Gathering I'm just
saying you might be able to find someone
somewhere who's actually a Marxist there
is not a single Marxist in a position of
power in federal government that I can
think of in the United States so when
the right talks about cultural Marxism
they don't even really know what they're
talking about it's not Marxism it
doesn't exist and it's thinly veiled
anti-Semitism so but that wasn't the
worst moment of this entire thing then
DeSantis is asked
what makes you different than Trump when
Nikki Haley was asked this question she
said I'm a woman of color and I'm
younger
when Tim Scott was asked what makes you
different from Trump he didn't even
really answer and he said there will be
a stark contrast by which I guess he
means he's younger than Trump and he's
black
does Ron DeSantis actually answer the
question let's see yeah so why now and
what distinguishes you from from the
other candidates are there policy
differences or is it more about
electability and how you would Implement
those policies even if you agree on them
I don't know
well why now I think it's because the
country's going in the wrong direction
we have another four years of the Biden
Administration I think some of the
damage is going to be irreversible I
think we have an opportunity now kind of
like the late 1970s when Jimmy Carter
was President uh to really move the
country in a much stronger Direction and
really bring a lot of bold leadership to
Bear uh why me well I think what we've
been able to do in Florida is two things
one we've had unprecedented policy
success all the things that we believe
as Republicans or as conservatives for
many many years we've been able to take
those values and those principles and
actually turn them into reality every
single day we put up big wins on the
board but we're doing that while also
enjoying major political success you
alluded to it we were able to win
re-election by a historical margin so as
you can see he doesn't actually say what
distinguishes him from Trump when he was
asked about the military
and exactly what he would do with
Ukraine he talked about gender ideology
I'm not kidding guys I'm not kidding
look at this
all right you uh wore the uniform if you
are elected president you may be the
first one in a while uh to have worn the
uniform how would you address the
ongoing war in Eastern Europe between
Russia and Ukraine on day one of Iran
DeSantis presidents good question
well first I think what we need to do as
a veteran is recognize that our military
has become politicized you talk about
gender ideology you talk about things
like global warming that they're somehow
concerned and that's not the military
that I served in we need to return our
military to focusing on uh commitment
focusing on the core values and the core
Mission wow that would be something that
I could take care of on day one uh
there'll be a new sheriff in town as
commander-in-chief and I think you'll
see recruiting start to get back to
where it needs to be because people
don't want to join award as if the
military is not big enough military and
I think it's been really really
problematic look in terms of what's
going on over in Eastern Europe you know
I'd like to see a settlement of this I
do not want to see a wider War okay so
what he would do is he would he wants
the war to end is what he would do but
woke in the military is really the
problem
disastrous interview is that going to
convince Mega voters to switch to
DeSantis from Trump let's give it a few
days and see where the polling lands one
of the best ways to support this show is
by supporting our sponsors today one of
those sponsors is sheath underwear it is
spring temperatures are rising many of
us know all too well about the sweating
and the sticking and the chafing but
that's only when you use traditional
underwear when you use sheath underwear
it's no longer a problem sheath
underwear is ergonomically designed with
separate compartments in the front to
keep everything dry cool and separate
and to keep you comfortable they come in
a zillion different designs something
for everybody the quality is amazing
super long lasting put an end to the
readjusting and the sweating and the
shifting uncomfortably sheath underwear
is really a lifesaver you will thank
yourself it's a unique product you've
got to try at least once to see for your
self and my audience gets 20 off with
code Pacman go to sheathunderwear.com
Pacman the link is down below